SPEAKER:  I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR
THE LIBRARY CENTER HERE AT THE
LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.  AND I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME YOU THIS
AFTERNOON.  THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.  THIS IS A
REALLY SPECIAL DAY AND WE ARE
HERE TO CELEBRATE A SERIES OF
EVENTS THAT STARTS THIS
AFTERNOON.  SO TODAY WE HAVE
HERE TO CELEBRATE THE CONCLUSION
OF THE SECOND TERM OF THE YEAR
OF POET LAUREATE, JUAN FELIPE
HERRERA.  WHAT AN HONOR AND A
PRIVILEGE IT IS TO BE PART OF
THE AMAZING DAY, BECAUSE OF THE
REMARKABLE MAN.  I USE THE WORD
MAGICAL.  JUST MAGICAL.  THAT IS
WHAT I AM TALKING ABOUT.  JUST
EXCUSE ME WHILE I TALK DIRECTLY
TO HIM.  WE ARE HERE TO
CELEBRATE YOU AND HONOR YOU FOR
YOUR WORK AND YOUR SERVICE TO
THE COUNTRY.  AND IN
REPRESENTATION OF THE POET
LAUREATESHIP, THERE HAVE BEEN A
REMARKABLE SERIES OF ACTIVITIES
AND EVENTS OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS.  TODAY WE CELEBRATE
WITH SOME MORE REMARKABLE EVENTS
CULMINATING WITH A NEW
CONCERT TODAY.  AND FESTIVITIES
THAT I MENTIONED.  ANDLY START
BY SAYING THAT TODAY'S SERIES OF
EVENTS ARE BROUGHT BY THE
POETRY CENTER IN PART WITH THE
FOCALIZED CENTER AND THE SPANISH
DIVISION IN THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.  AND HERE THE LIBRARY,
IT'S OUR MISSION TO REALLY
PROMOTE OURSELVES AS THE FIRST
CULTURAL CONSTITUTION AND IN
SERVICE OF BEING THE FIRST
CULTURAL CONSTITUTION WE FOCUS
ON PROVIDING AMERICAN PEOPLE
GLOBALLY WITH A RICH AND DIVERSE
ENDURING SOURCE OF THE
KNOWLEDGE.  FOR INTELLECTUAL AND
CREATIVE ENDEAVORS.  AND WE
ESPECIALLY BELIEVE THAT OUR
PARTNER AND THE EVENTS TODAY AND
TOMORROW.  THIS IS THE FIRST
SPARK AND INCLUDES MR.
HERRERA'S HOMETOWN.  AND PERFORM
KEY PIECES DURING
COLLABORATION. AND THE
PERFORMANCE CREDIT WILL INCLUDE
FESTIVALS AND MEMBERS OF THE
CHAMBER SINGERS HAVE TOURED
MEXICO.
CHINA.  AND EVEN EUROPE.  FOR
THE OWN 2016, 2017 SEASON.  AND
I AM THANKFUL TO SEVERAL
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE MAKING THIS
CONCERT HAPPEN INCLUDING THE
DEAN OF THE COLLEGE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES.
AND JULIE SANDOVAL.  THANK YOU.
HELLO.
[APPLAUSE].  THANK YOU
TO THE CABINET.  WELCOME ACROSS
THE COUNTRY VIEWING US.  WE WANT
TO MAKE NOTE THAT THE
FESTIVITIES WILL CONTINUE AFTER
ODD IT'S CONCERT THIS EVENING AT
7 P.M. IN THE THOMAS JEFFERSON
BUILDING AND THE CLUGE
AUDITORIUM.  THERE IS A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
CONTINUING EMERGENC OF THE
LATINO CULTURE WITH JUAN FELIPE
HERRERA AND FOLLOWED BY A
CONCERT WITH THE GRAMMY AWARD
WINNING EAST LA ROCK BAND.
THE CONDUCTOR OF THE FRESNO
STATE CHAMBER AND THE COLLECTOR
OF ACTIVITIES.  AND A PHENOMENAL
ARTIST WITH HER OWN RIGHTS AND
COMBINED WITH CAREER, CONDUCTOR,
TEACHER AND SINGER AND SHE IS
IN DEMAND AS
A CONDUCTOR.  AND ABROAD AND
PERFORMANCE AND ADVANCED DEGREES
WITH PRODUCTION AND PEDAGOGY.
PLEASE WELCOME CARI EARN
HART.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OF
FRESNO, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
WE ARE HONORED BE TO A PART OF
THIS EVENT WITH FELI
PE.
TODAY'S PROGRAM WILL FEATURE
FIVE COMPOSITIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUES, AND THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME JUAN
FELIPE'S WORDS HAVE BEEN SET TO
SONG.  AND GIVEN A NEW LIFE.
THESE PIECES AS YOU WILL SEE
TELL THE STORY OF A MAN THROUGH
HIS JOURNEY, NOT JUST THE LAST
TWO YEARS AS
POET LAUREATE.
[MUSIC]
AND I WILL SING AND CARRY THE
SOUNDS OF THE PEOPLE
IN ETERNAL.
THE SUNRISE, I WILL WALK PAST
THE WILDERNESS.
AND THE LAST GIVING THANKS.
AND THE FLOURISHING WORDS.
REMEMBER ALL THE
ANCESTORS.  [MUSIC]
I AM THE YOUNGEST VOICE, CHILD,
AND I WILL SAY TO YOU ALWAYS,
REACH IN EVERY ONE OF YOU.  I
SING.  I AM THE FIRST
GRANDCHILD.  AND SAFETY DELIVERS
TO EACH AND EVERY ONE OF YOU, I
WILL SING FOR EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF
YOU.
I WILL SING.  [APPLAUSE].
AND I WAS ALWAYS, YOU KNOW,
SPEAKING SPANISH.  THAT IS MY
LANGUAGE.  AND I HAVE BEEN
PROHIBITED FROM
SPEAKING IN SPANISH IN SAN
DIEGO, CALIFORNIA.  SO COME ON.
COME UP.  COME ON
UP AND STEP.  AND I SAID I
DON'T KNOW IF I CAN DO THAT TO
MYSELF.  I SAID I DON'T THINK
SO.  BUT YOU KNOW, NO ONE HAS
EVER SAID TO THAT YOU.  NO ONE
EVER SAID THAT TO YOU.  WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN?  I STEPPED UP TO
THE FRONT AS BEST AS I COULD.
THE BIG OPERA.  [LAUGHTER].  AND
THEN SHE TURNED TO
ME.  AND SHE SAID, YOU HAVE A
BEAUTIFUL VOICE.  AND TO THIS
VERY DAY, THIS VERY MOMENT, THAT
WAS THE KEY TO LIFE.  AND I
TOOK THAT KEY.  AND I TOOK THOSE
ROADS AND GAVE THEM TO EVERY
WOMEN.  AND THAT WAS WHAT SHE
WAS TELLING ME.  THAT THE BEAUTY
IN MY VOICE WAS THE BEAUTY IN
EVERYONE'S
VOICES.  YES.  [MUSIC].
[MUSIC]
FEEL A LITTLE BETTER.  FEEL A
LITTLE TALLER.  KEEP ON WALKING.
KEEP
ON STEPPING.  I'M A
KING.
I'M A KING.  YES, I'M SINGING.
HERE FOR THE PEOPLE.  I MADE A
CHOICE.  TO SING FOR THE PEOPLE.
AND HEAR THE VOICE.  LET ME HEAR
YOUR VOICE.  AND EVERYBODY
SING.
HEAR MY VOICE.  EVERYBODY SINGS.
HEAR MY VOICE.  EVERYBODY HERE.
HEAR MY
VOICE.  HEAR MY VOICE.
WE WANT TO HEAR MY VOICE.  COME
TO HEAR MY VOICE.  HEAR MY
VOICE.  SING IT FOR THE HUMS.
HEAR MY VOICE.  SING IT.  HEAR
MY
VOICE.  HEAR MY VOICE.  HEAR MY
VOICE.
HEAR MY VOICE.
[APPLAUSE].
SINGING.  IT BEGAN TO GROW. IT
BEGAN TO GROW AS TIME WENT ON.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENED WAS THAT
IN FRESNO RECENTLY I OPENED UP
THE LAUREATE LAST, AND PRESIDENT
WAS SO KIND.  AND LESLIE WAS SO
KIND.  AND THE LIBRARIAN WAS SO
KIND, PETER MCDONALD AND OUR
DEAN OF HUMANITIES WAS SO KIND.
AND A STUDENT
CAME TO THE CENTER FOR THE LAB.
WHERE WE EXPLORED AND
EXPERIMENT WITH WORDS AND PAINT
AND PLASTIC WALLS AND MURALS AND
SCULPTURES AND PLASTICS AND
POETRY.  AND FULL OF INTENSITY
AND PASSION FOR LANGUAGE AND
POETRY.  BEAUTIFUL TALENT.
AMAZING COMING TO CLASS ONE DAY.
AND WAS COMING TO THE COLLEGE
ONE DAY AND WAS TORRENTIAL RAIN
AT THAT MOMENT WHEN SHE WAS
GETTING TO FREEWAY 41.  SO SHE
MADE A TURN INTO THE FREEWAY.
AND THAT RAIN AND ALL THAT
HAPPENED AT THAT MOMENT CAUSED
HER TO FLIP OVER INTO THE NEXT
LANE OF THE OPPOSITE WING.
AND A BIG TRUCK CAME AND THAT
WAS THE END OF HER LIFE.  SO IN
ONE OF HER POEMS, WHICH IS
CALLED I AM WITH UNITED STATES
SHOWS YOU THE KIND OF PASSION
SHE HAS.  WE USED TO HAVE TODAY,
BEAUTIFUL AMAZING CHOIR.  AND
THAT'S THE INTENSITY.  AND
THAT'S THE POEMS THAT WE ARE
GOING TO SING, THAT THIS
BEAUTIFUL CHOIR IS GOING TO COME
TO YOU.  THE BEAUTIFUL POEMS.
AND ALL OF THE WOMEN, ALL OF THE
STUDENTS AND ALL OF YOU AND
EVERYONE.  I AM UNDECIDED.  THE
THING THAT PASSES BY
BURNING INTO ME.  AND KEEPS IT
OPEN FOR RECEIVER TO
THESE OPEN DOORS.
THE ONES I KNOW.  RAIN DOWN ON
MY NECK.  ALL THAT BEATS ON MY
LIPS.  DOWN THE LANE NO
WAY, NO WAY.  I AM SINGING TO
THE
UNITED STATES, WHY I AM
WITH THE UNITED STATES.  MS.
UNITED STATES.  WE ARE MS.
UNITED STATES.  [MUSIC].
MEET ME DOWN THE AVENUE AND MAKE
ME STAY OUTSIDE AND IT WAS THE
LAST ONE JOINING AND THE LAST
ONE SINGING, AND THE LAST
ONE SAYING.
GO HEAT AND LOOK AGAIN AND YOU
CAN'T DENY IT.  YOU CAN'T DENY
IT.  YOU CAN'T DENY IT.
I
AM MS. UNITED STATES.  I AM MS.
UNITED STATES.
I AM MS.
WE ARE THE PEOPLE.  MS.
UNITED STATES.  MS.
UNITED STATES.
[APPLAUSE].
ON POEM, PARADING DOWN
BLACKSTONE AVENUE.  AND THAT
VOICE, THAT POEM HAS REACHED ALL
OF US WITH THE VOICES OF OUR
CHAMBER CITIES.  AND NOW YOU
HAVE THE VOICE.  AND HER
ENCOURAGEMENT AND HER ENERGY.
AND THEN IT MAKES ME ASK THE
QUESTION.  WHAT CAN A POEM DO?
WHAT DO WE DO WHEN IT TAKES
PLACE?  SOMETHING THAT LEAVES US
HELPLESS.  SOMETHING THAT IS
FAR AWAY.  MAYBE IT'S BOSTON.
MAYBE IT'S A TERRIBLE INCIDENT.
AND MAYBE IT'S THE MASSACRE
THAT WE ALL KNOW ABOUT IN SOUTH
CAROLINA.  SO I SAID WHAT CAN I
DO -- I THINK WHAT WE CAN ALL DO
IS MAKE AN OFFERING. MAYBE IT'S
TO MEDICATE ON IT.  MAYBE IT'S
TO SAY HELLO.  AND ITS BEING
INTIMATE AND CARING.  AND MAYBE
IT'S ALSO A POEM THAT WE CAN
WRITE AND SEND TO THE PEOPLE.
AND THIS POEM, POEM BY POEM,
SPEAKS ABOUT THIS.  AND IT WAS
RECEIVED IN SOUTH CAROLINA AND
PUT ON A NEWS LETTER IN THAT
AREA IN PARTICULAR.  AND POEM BY
POEM, WE CAN END THE VIOLENCE.
[MUSIC].  POEM BY POEM WE CAN
END THE VIOLENCE.  EVERY DAY.
POEM BY
POEM.  POEM BY
POEM.
EVERY OTHER DAY.  POEM BY POEM.
WE CAN
END THE VIOLENCE.
POEM BY POEM.  WE CAN END THE
VIOLENCEVIOLENCE
POEM BY POEM.
POEM BY
POEM.  THEY'RE ALL I KNOW.  THEY
ARE NOT NINE.  THEY
ARE
EACH ONE LIVE.  YOU HAVE A POEM
OFFER.
IT IS MADE OF ACTION.  YOU MUST
HAVE A POEM TO OFFER.
TO OFFER TO THE WORLD.
YOU HAVE A
POEM.
WHEN YOU FIND IT.
STOP THEM
FROM FALL.  STOP THEM FROM FALL.
STOP THEM FROM FALLING.
[APPLAUSE].
[DRUMS BEATING].
HIS?  WHO ARE YOU?  WHAT AM I?
I'M A 5TH GRADER.  I COME FROM
THE VALUES.  I'M AN ONLY SON.  I
COME FROM THE
FUMES.  WHAT ARE YOU?  I DO NOT
HAVE A PLACE.  I DON'T KNOW A
STREET.  I AM HERE.
INVISIBLE.  I DO NOT KNOW.  I
MUST BE SOMETHING.  MAYBE FROM
THE ISLAND.  MAYBE I'M HAWAIIAN.
I WANT TO SING MEXICAN.  BUT I
CANNOT SAY IT.  THE FIRE INSIDE
IS ALL I HAVE.  YOU KNOW, IF I
HAD A
SAXAPHONE, I WOULD BLOW IT AN
ALL THE STREETS AND OPEN ITS
BELL SHAPED MOUTH AND MAKE IT
COME ALIVE.  IF I CAN MAKE EVERY
STREET COME ALIVE.  AND THE
VOICE.  VOICE.  VOICE.  IF ONLY
I HAD A CHOICE.  I WOULD SING.
I WOULD RING OUT THE BELLS.  AND
TALK ABOUT THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN NEVER BEEN TOLD FROM THE
FIELD TO THE MOUNTAINS AND
VALLEYS AND THE YARDS AND THE
FIELDS, I WOULD SAY, YEAH,
WE ARE ONE PROVEN.  IN THE
GOLDEN LIGHT OF THE VOICE.  NO
SAXAPHONE FOR ME.
SO BASS FOR ME.  I WILL HIDE
BEHIND.  AND POINT TO THE BACK.
AND I WANT TO BREAK FREE FROM
ALL OF THE
LIES.  I WANT TO BREAK FREE FROM
ALL OF THE SHAME OF BEING
ALONE.  AND WITH THE MELODY AND
THE TONE.  SPEAKING WORDS.  LET
ME HAVE FUN.  I WANT TO BREAK
FREE.  LEAVE MY VOICE ALONE.
SOMETIMES LIKE A CRY, MY VOICE
ALONE UNDER THE TREES UP SO HIGH
AND THE VOICE CAME.  AND YES,
IT
CAME.  IT CAME.  AND CALLED
POWER.  THEY CALL POWER.
BLACK POWER.  THEY CALL BROWN
POWER.  WOMEN'S POWER.  POWER,
POWER.  YELL POWER.  POWER,
POWER,
POWER, FOR THE PEOPLE.
[SPEAKING SPANISH].  FOR YOU.
AND MAYBE ME.  ON THE ROAD.
WHERE DO I GO?  HOW DO I MAKE MY
VOICE CRY?  HOW DO YOU MAKE
YOUR VOICE KNOW WHY?  HOW DO YOU
GIVE YOUR VOICE TO THE PEOPLE?
DO YOU STAND ON YOUR HEELS, A
STAPLE OR JUST TAKE A STEP ON
THE ROAD NEAR AND FAR.  FAR,
FAR, FAR.  TAKE A STEP.  ON THE
ROAD.  COME UP TO THE FRONT.
BUT WHERE?  HOW FAR?  THE ROAD
OF THE PEOPLE.  DO THEY HAVE A
VOICE?  WHO STARTED?  YOU?  WHY
AREN'T THEY HEARD?  DID YOU STOP
THEM?  YOU HAVE A VOICE.  DON'T
YOU SEE?  YOU CAN TELL THEIR
STORIES.  YOU CAN SPEAK THEM.
CAN YOU WRITE THEM?  CAN YOU
SING THEM?  BE A POET.  BE A
POET.  AND YOU FIND, DON'T
FORGET, NOW IS THE TIME.  ALL
THE VOICES NEED A SLICE MADE OF
LOVE.  NOW IS THE TIME.  ALL THE
VOICES MADE OF LIFE, OF LOVE,
OF STRIVE.  DO YOU DARE?  I DO
NOT KNOW.  WHAT ABOUT IF THEY
WOULD HAVE?  THERE IS NO CHOICE.
WHAT IF NO ONE CARED?  AND
WHAT
IF I HAVE NO VOICE.  THE ROAD
IS LONG.  THE ROAD IS LOST.  NO
ONE KNOWS.  THE ROAD IS YOU.
THE ROAD IS NEW.  WHEN DO I ACT?
THE PART.
MIDDLE IT ALL.  BLACK AND DEEP
AND THINGS BURNED.  THINGS
TURNED.  AND BE LIKE ME.  I'M
GOING TO LOOK AHEAD.  THE
SMASHER.  BE LIKE ME.  SHOULD
HAVE WROTE THIS AS YOU LOOK OUT.
[SPEAKING SPANISH].  I AM THE
ONE THAT DIPS INTO THE STEW.
THE ONE THE WITCHES TURN AND
SPIN AND BREW.  THE CREATOR.
THE ONE
THAT TICKLES.  AND THE ONE THAT
TURNS YOU INTO
A RIVER AND TO GROW.  AND THE
TABLE THAT
BRINGS FAMILY TOGETHER.  GIVE
ME A WORD.  NOT ABSURD.  GIVE ME
A SPICY WORD.  GIVE ME A WISDOM
WORD.  GIVE ME A WORD FOR
OTHERS.  GIVE ME A WORD FOR
PEACE.  GIVE ME A WORD TO TEACH.
GIVE ME A
WORD.
FOR LOVE.
[SINGING] [DRUMS]
I HAVE A WORD.
WHAT DO I DO?  I HAVE MY WORDS.
WHERE
DO I GO?
[MUSIC].
[APPLAUSE].
THANKING SO MUCH TO ALL OF YOU.
AND THANK YOU CARI FOR THE
PERFORMANCE.  THANKS TO EVERYONE
TODAY WHO HELPED TO MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE.  AND OF COURSE, THANK
YOU TO THE CONSULTANT POETRY.
[APPLAUSE].
THANK YOU.  THANK
YOU.  I JUST HAVE TWO QUICK
THINGS TO TELL YOU AND THEN YOU
CAN GO OUT AND ENJOY THE DAY.
ONE, YOU SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN
SURVEYS WITH YOUR PROGRAMS.  IF
YOU DON'T MIND FILLING THEM OUT
AND YOU CAN LEAVE THEM ON YOUR
CHAIR.  IT WILL BE HELPFUL FOR
US WHEN WE WORK ON FUTURE
PROGRAMS.  TWO, AS WE TALKED
ABOUT DEVELOPMENT A LITTLE BIT
BEFORE, THERE ARE EVENTS GOING
ON THIS EVENING.  7:00
PERFORMANCE DOWN STAIRS IN THE
KLUGE AND OUTSIDE, THERE ARE
AMAZING DISPLAYS OF OUR
COLLECTIONS FROM THE SPONSORING
LIBRARY DIVISION WHO HAS HELPED
TO MAKE THIS POSSIBLE.  GO DOWN
AND CHECK OUT.  MAKE SURE TO
COME BACK EARLY AND IT'S GOING
TO BE A PACKED PERFORMANCE